cyril je voulais dire quelque chose six
mois cette fois la star il al'air
chocolat est cyril je voulais dire
quelque chose six mois ça fait face à la
star il al'air chocolat si je te dis mon
coeur
si je te dis qu'il ya un vrai que les
accords ou quoi ça chantait dit si je te
dis pierre est ce que tu te rappelles
parce que il ya didier marty qui nous a
rejoint
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
et je te plait merci je connais assez
pressé il ya star trek carrie léché
machine j'ai une surprise pour toi est
ce que tu te rappelles de gens de pierre
de genre de jean pierre boulât c'est
pierre serre oui oui y'en a plein je me
rappelle ça faisait bien longtemps
c'est c est ce que tu te rappelles d'un
slot tu as dansé avec un pire l'an 2000
à trappes où la foule avait bondi
d'autres dossiers dossier pierre
d'assise doit dire oui
non mais tu avais 15 ans oui tu t'en
rappelles ou pas et ben pierre est là
cette foire regardez bombe a fait leur
entrée maintenant tout le monde a
compris entre autres et pierre pierre
c'est un vaccin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est alors chaïma mais dans ces caméras
souple et chérie pierre est ce que tu es
content de voir pierre je serre les
dents de sanctions sans pourtant jamais
cessé
je sais que vous avez dansé un sous
ensemble pierre maille a new day shy'm
est ce que vous voulez refaire ce chiot
pour nous ce soir
qu'est ce qui va nous mettre c'était sur
quoi le slogan c'est sûr aimé ce déchet
il a eu également joue pas ça arrête
petite arvine est moi shy'm lui venait
la pierre la mettez vous la mettez vous
vous remettez vous là et c'est précis il
faut prévenir pour sa danse de choisir à
quoi ça vous fait plaisir de le revoir
ben oui mais comme ça ici c'est déjà un
peu souple et crédit g qu'avec valérie
tout ça revenait la non vous êtes où il
se sent isolé dans m'arrêter moi je veut
s'assurer que ça devrait vous êtes vous
encore s'est pas vu géraldine aussi
mettez vous là bas alors les cherry est
ce que vous voulez nous refaire le selon
aimé comme avant ça m'a bien sur la meme
si je voudrais demander à didier marty
de bien vouloir nous remettre de m le
saut à paniquer mais c'est celle perdue
en bon sens
côté
ap
c'est en fait
pierre chalard été dominés et chaque
check je vous sens inouï de revoir
pierre il parvient ce que moi je peux
dire quelque chose tellement hâte en
syrie le pardon il allait alors pire
c'est quand votre nom de famille est
bien pire il s'appelle comment est ce
que tu te rappelles de son nom de
famille à pierre mondy mais vous êtes
sûr je vais te fait te chercher c'est
quoi la paire colada la médaille vous
restez là bas et je vous mettais pas la
sublime et évidemment avec moi alors
mettez-vous l'abbatiale me mettez vous
là bas allaient nous mettez vous mettez
pas la table si vous ne croyez pas
moment d'émotion pour pierre que la
saison vient alors allez-y relancer
c'est uniquement
sortez battant les mettez vous la mettez
vous devant rien mais tu rajoutes de
regarder celle ci au point qu'elle y
mettez vous devant voilà vous êtes avec
martin sont marty voilà mes chéris s'il
vous plaît martic sks cyril je voulais
dire quelque chose qui moi ça fait face
à bastia il al'air chocolat
[Applaudissements]
les manteaux
[Musique]